[Music]
it's what everybody Florida marching
here from loads of gaming dot now I'm
here with Vlad from another indie studio
how you doing today hey man pretty great
great great so we're gonna talk about
drew man Rumble is right behind me tell
us a little bit about the game so drill
man Rumble is indie game from China it's
actually from the creator of lost castle
so it's their new game so it's a eight
player arena brawler so you can play it
online and offline as well and the way
it works its one-hit kill and you use
drills to fight each other so drills
have also special abilities and you have
different characters and there's a
plethora of different gaming modes as
well it's like a deaf match and then you
have a pursuit you have Kenny king of a
crown then you have a point system that
you have bounties as well and it's gonna
be coming out later this year in early
access but we're also releasing it on
the switch and Xbox and Playstation and
PC as well it's a lot of information
about the game it's great that's great
it sounds amazing it's looking for Tatsu
what so how many were actually working
on the game that's a lot of content you
were talking about this currently the
studio is about 12 people wow there's a
small team yeah yeah did the first game
they did what they were only three and
that game exploded so they expanded
their team and they're finishing up this
one
well the gameplay sounds intense so ice
actually check out some gameplay of what
we see on screen here so kind of break
it down like the strategies you want to
go into Jerome and Rumble so we the game
is deciding a way to have like very fast
quick fire matches so it's not gonna
drag out four minutes usually like 40
seconds to 50 seconds so every character
has their special ability and then you
use that to your advantage obviously and
then also they have different drills you
can choose on in a different drill as a
different ability also after 15 to 20
seconds power up stop dropping which are
like shields electricity bombs actually
changing out the game there yes and then
after 30 seconds you start getting big
mechs and rocket ships that you can pile
it as well so those give you extra lives
and vigor to be
advantage on the playing field because
they can fly around or move faster okay
and I see here that each player has at
least three lives correct no no each
player has only one lives it's okay okay
one hit kill unless you have some
special ability okay okay so what kind
of abilities will player seek I've see
we have at least what round a more than
eight characters here so for example you
have the death knight so he has two lies
when you kill him once he gets up you
have to kill him again if you don't and
he regenerates and next he's gonna be
pretty popular yeah and then you have
the ghost which is actually you right
selected right now so this one can go
invisible so people can't see it core
targeted Oh new favorite new favorite
this character can fly around the map if
you go up this one has like a ground
slam that stuns enemies there's a ton of
iearning these characters that each
character has a special skill in
addition to the different drills you can
choose as well which add the special
attack option awesome awesome
so you put the amount of content you're
planning on you say you have online
correct okay we have what give online so
you'll be able to play up to eight
players online and local perfect perfect
well show me and Rumble looks like an
exciting title especially a great party
game for people out there so what you
people expect to play it again
later this year we're launching I think
quarter two or three in the early access
and then full release will be probably
at the end of the year or beginning of
next one
amazingamazing one more time with some
platforms for people out there know
where to find the game so it's gonna be
on Steam first in early access and then
full release or again on Steam and then
switch Xbox and PlayStation 4 you hear
it here first on Lords of gaming that
net is lower monster signing off because
you guys late here at PAX East 2020
[Music]